-Hey guys, last week was crazy.
Election day should have been
one night,
but it ended up being almost
an entire week.
But anyways,
we wanted to say thank you
to all of the hard-working
journalists and reporters
who didn't get much sleep
in order to bring us the news.
Thank you, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Especially Steve Kornacki,
our very own.
Kornacki was up late.
I was getting scared.
At one point he was kind of
falling down.
He was just like -- He'd wobble.
I'd be like, "Oh, hold Kornacki.
I can't let him go down.
It's too important.
But I did want to say thank you,
so I decided to surprise him
at his office.
Man his office is just a mess.
[ Laughter ]
He's just downstairs.
He's in our building at MSNBC.
So I just surprised him
this afternoon. Take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, here we go.
Gonna find Kornacki.
Is Steve Kornacki there?
We're here.
We are at the right place.
Look, MSNBC, this is the floor.
Gosh, it's dark in here.
Are these temporary offices?
Kornacki?
This is like bizarre.
Steve Kornacki's office.
[ Deep voice ]
Hello, can I come in?
What's up, dude? [ Laughs ]
-How are you doing? Wow!
-Oh, my.
-This is the office?
[ Laughter ]
What in the world?
God.
-Welcome to the second floor.
-Steve Kornacki, the legend,
the heart throb himself.
Come on out, buddy.
Steve, you're still standing.
You're doing all right.
-I am recharged.
I'm feeling okay.
-Feeling great?
What happens now to you, though.
-They put me back into
preservation
for about three
and a half years.
Yeah.
-I got you a little something
because, you know --
This is for you.
-Okay. Look at that.
-Yeah.
-Oh.
-It is a Subway $5 gift card
and a bottle of Jack.
We love you.
-This is really kind of you.
I wish I had something for you.
You're welcome to --
-I don't want anything...
-There is not much in here.
-...to do with that office.
[ Laughter ]
-Steve Kornacki, everybody!
The one and only.
Good job, buddy. Fist bump.
-Alright. Thanks for visiting.
-Yeah, no problem.
We'll be back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.